[Musica]
vi parlo di questo dei condannati non
dannati Io sono un avvocato penalista
Come vi è stato detto
e durante il covid durante la pandemia
ho iniziato a parlare con il mio
telefono perché tutte le giornate erano
uguali
di giorno il tempo non passava la sera
mi ritrovavo lì a casa da sola Poi
quando ho riniziato a lavorare perché i
tribunali hanno
aperto era ancora peggio perché lavoravo
tutto il giorno mi sentivo una
formichina poi la sera stavo chiusa in
casa e quindi a un certo punto ho preso
il telefono in mano e ho iniziato a
sfogarmi Perché uno che cosa fa la sera
quando torna a casa con con le persone
con cui saa si sfoga e racconta le cose
che gli succedono nella vita e quindi io
che cosa ho iniziato raccontare quello
che succede nella mia vita quello che
vedo tutti i giorni nelle aree di
giustizia nelle carceri E vi
assicuro vi assicuro che si vede davvero
di tutto Ed è per questo che ho iniziato
a parlare e ho chiamato la mia rubrica
giustizia distorta perché di storture
nel nostro sistema giudiziario Purtroppo
ce ne sono veramente tante le persone
che finiscono in questa macchina
eh è una macchina veramente uno schiacci
sassi ma solo chi solo gli addetti ai
lavori conoscono questo mondo chi ne sta
fuori non non sa veramente quello che
accade e quando mi è stato detto che il
titolo di l'argomento di questo tedex
sarebbe stato spazio e tempo Io ho
subito ho pensato ai
detenuti al loro spazio interrotto e al
loro tempo
sospeso
Perché se voi ci pensate Noi viviamo in
una realtà dove i detenuti non esistono
le carceri non esistono nel momento in
cui tu vieni arrestato vieni preso
prelevato da quella che è la nostra
realtà e vieni messo in un'altra
realtà e queste persone vengono
dimenticate vengono emarginate e si
ritrovano lì
reclusi vedendo tutta la vita che scorre
fuori e loro non ne fanno più parte sono
totalmente messi appunto in uno spazio
totalmente diverso dal
nostro un po' Come possiamo immaginare
noi come quando c'è stata appunto la
pandemia Quando c'è stata la pandemia
noi il tempo non passava mai e E io lo
so che voi state pensando E vabbè però
noi il covid non l'abbiamo voluto loro
invece qualcosa No devono aver pur fatto
se lo meritano Comunque il carcere
perché qualcosa hanno fatto bene Vi
faccio una piccola premessa se
sicuramente qualcuno si merita diciamo
una pena un qualcosa da da scontare
Dobbiamo ricordarci che nelle nostre
carceri la popolazione
carceraria della popolazione carceraria
fanno parte l' 85% i detenuti comuni e
il 15% le sezioni speciali che cosa vuol
dire delle sezioni speciali fanno parte
quei detenuti condannati per i reati
quelli considerati più gravi di allarme
sociale quindi criminalità organizzata
terrorismo omicidi tutti gli altri su
55.000 detenuti circa tutti gli altri
sono
condannati oppure imputati per reati
bagatellari per
qualche per reati finanziari magari per
dei piccoli furti Quella è la nostra
popolazione carceraria Questo è il
motivo per cui cui le nostre carceri
sono
sovraffollate bene ma soprattutto noi
dobbiamo ricordarci che di tutte queste
persone una parte è stata condannata ed
è condannata definitivamente Cioè ci
sono i definitivi i cosiddetti
definitivi ma l'altra parte gli altri
detenuti sono lì in misura cautelare Voi
sapete che cos'è una misura cautelare
sapete cosa Chi sono i detenuti in
misura cautelare sono quelli per cui
magari un processo non è ne anche
iniziato non solo non c'è stato un grado
di giudizio Ma magari le indagini sono
ancora in corso Ci sono delle volte
alcuni detenuti che aspettano anche 2
anni in carcere prima che il loro
processo
incominci questi sono Questa è la nostra
popolazione carceraria e sapete la cosa
più bella è che da noi esiste anche
l'ingiusta retenzione ed è
difficilissimo ottenerla non la
ottengono tutte le persone assolte che
sono circa una persona su quattro Per
mia esperienza personale gli assolti
sono circa uno su quattro ma i casi di
ingiusta detenzione in Italia nel 2022
sono stati
539 e di errori giudiziari invece ce ne
stanno stati OT questo per una spesa
complessiva dello stato di più di 37
milioni di euro non so se vi rendete
conto e ripeto per ottenere questa
ingiusta detenzione Ma voi non avete la
la difficoltà e le condizioni stringenti
che sono
richieste e quindi che cosa succede noi
facciamo finta per un attimo Facciamo
finta che chi è in carcere tutti quelli
che sono in carcere si meritino la pena
perché magari hanno commesso un reato
gravissimo perché magari
sono e quindi sono in misura cautelare o
perché magari sono stati condannati
definitivamente con una senenza
irrevocabile e
davvero la pena devono scontare una pena
diciamo giusta ma la pena ha due
funzioni
principali la funzione retributiva e la
funzione rieducativa Qual è la funzione
retributiva Questa è quella che risponde
di più e soddisfa di più la sete di
vendetta la sete di vendetta comune dove
la gente dice Ecco la pena esemplare
Finalmente una persona è in carcere deve
stare lì deve stare lì bisogna buttare
via la chiave queste Questa è una cella
di San Vittore Queste sono le
carceri La cassazione ha deciso che ogni
detenuto abbia deve avere a disposizione
almeno 3 m qu 3 m qu Peccato che questa
cosa non accada mai infatti Noi abbiamo
un numero di sovraffollamento
incredibile veniamo condannati
continuamente dalla Corte europea perché
in una cella di tendenzialmente 9 m qu
dove dovrebbero stare quindi al massimo
tre detenuti dovete sapere che ci stanno
4 5 se detenuti e in questa cella qua
devono starci tutto il giorno perché le
ore d'aria sono una manciata la mattina
e un paio d'ore il pomeriggio e lì
devono cucinare mangiare andare in bagno
perché il bagno molto spesso fa parte
della Cella e molto spesso non c'è
neanche la porta il lavandino
chiaramente viene usato per tutto sia
per come per il bagno sia che per la
cucina per tutto pensate voi cosa vuol
dire stare in un ambiente così 24 ore su
24 7 giorni su
7 secondo voi è utile una pena così può
essere utile perché i nostri costituenti
ovvero Chi ha scritto la
Costituzione credeva tanto nell'utilità
della pena la pena deve essere utile ma
non utile a qualcuno deve essere utile
in generale che Che cosa vuol dire
questo lo hanno messo nero su bianco
nella nostra Costituzione all'articolo
27 loro hanno scritto che la pena non
deve essere
disumana e soprattutto deve tendere alla
rieducazione del
condannato Secondo voi la cela che
abbiamo visto prima è contraria o no ha
un senso di umanità Io ho un detenuto ho
avuto ve ne potrei raccontare mille di
storie ma ho un detenuto che d'estate
chiaramente i ventilatori non si possono
utilizzare perché possono essere
pericolosissimi perché hanno le lame che
prendevano le lenzuola dei letti le
bagnavano le buttavano per terra e ci si
sdraiavano sopra per cercare un po' di
rinfrescarsi Perché facevano fatica a
sopravvivere Non a caso avete anche
visto il tasso di suicidi nelle carceri
se n'è parlato molto finalmente in
questi ultimi
anni purtroppo è gravissimo e queste
persone che cosa succede devono essere
rieducate ma cosa vuol dire
rieducazione vuol dire far studiare le
persone fargli fare delle attività
culturali farle lavorare all'interno del
carcere Peccato che solo il 20% della
popolazione carceraria lavori e poi
pensate a tutti quelli appunto che vi
dicevo prima in misura cautelare magari
entrano magari vengono assolti magari
non vengono assolti vengono condannati a
una pena
brevissima 2 anni un anno 3 anni cioè
neanche il tempo Figuratevi la
burocrazia che c'è in Italia Immaginati
in un carcere cercano lavoro in carcere
ci mettono 23 anni a trovarlo il tempo
di trovarlo sono già
fuori e quindi la rieducazione Diciamo
che non funziona benissimo Vi dicevo
solo il 20% D delle persone detenute
riesce ad accedere al lavoro e quindi
che cosa
avviene secondo voi in quell'ambiente lì
stando sempre lì 24 ore su 24 avviene il
contagio e non quello del virus che
dicevamo prima del coronavirus è
avvenuto anche quello in realtà ed è
stato gravissimo ma non avviene solo
quello avviene il contagio criminale
perché se tu entri in carcere hai rubato
non lo so una bicicletta hai commesso un
errore ma vi giuro che esiste l'anno
scorso in carcere c'era un ragazzo che
aveva rubato un paio di airpods per
farvi
capire secondo voi se viene a contatto
con una persona con un criminale diciamo
vero con uno spacciatore d'esperienza
con un truffatore d'esperienza e la
persona che viene buttata in
carcere e viene quindi tolta dal suo
spazio e dal suo tempo viene allontanata
quindi dalla famiglia ha perso il lavoro
quando poi viene ritol dal carcere e
riviene messa nella nostra società Chi è
che contatterà come Com'è che farà
sopravvivere chiaramente sarà chiamerà
l'amico di quello che ha conosciuto in
carcere che gli ha detto che se spaccia
la cocaina Allora lavora perché gli è
stato tolto tutto alle persone che van
le persone che finiscono in carcere gli
viene tolto tutto ad alcuni appunto
anche la vita perché se la tolgono non
riescono a
superarlo Eppure guardate qua
72% sapete che
cos'è questo è il tasso di
recidiva la recidiva vuol dire quando tu
Commetti di nuovo un altro reato il
tasso di recidiva per chi sta in carcere
è del
70% del
70% per chi invece
può accedere al lavoro fuori dal carcere
può accedere alle misure alternative il
testo di recidiva si abbassa du al 2%
dal 70 al 2 non ho detto dal 70 al 20 eh
dal 70 al 2% Per chi può accedere alle
misure alternative Cosa vuol dire Per
chi può andare a lavorare per chi può
andare magari a fare del volontariato
Questa è la differenza chiaramente parlo
delle persone che sono condannate a pene
detentive brevi Ma che sono la maggior
parte come vi dicevo prima i detenuti
Comuni sono l'
85% c'era Michel fouco che già negli
anni 70 questo filosofo francese ci
diceva infatti che il carcere è un
fallimento continuo sapete perché perché
il carcere ripete sempre se stesso il
carcere dovrebbe esistere per fare
crollare l'indice
di criminalità e invece rimane invariato
Pensate solo agli Stati Uniti dove le
pene sono altissime e in carcere
finiscono tutti è uno degli stati in cui
la criminalità Infatti non riesce mai
mai il tasso di criminalità non riesce
mai a scendere
mai Eppure Noi viviamo in una società
dove è bellissimo e ovunque sono titoli
di giornali con buttiamo via la
chiave pene certe carcere
duro viene anche sempre detto che
nessuno finisce in carcere stanno tutti
fuori non è così non è così ma
soprattutto anche se fosse così forse
sarebbe meglio perché come vi dicevo
prima il tempo e lo spazio che c'è in
carcere è uno spazio tossico Cioè voi
immaginate dopo 2 3 5 anni quando una
persona appunto condannata a una pena
breve viene presa da quello spazio e da
quel tempo e rimessa nella nostra
realtà secondo voi ci può essere può può
può migliorare in questo modo la nostra
società può trovare un giovamento
di da queste persone che sono buttate in
un in una cella giocare a carte O magari
a fare esercizi palestra tutto il giorno
Secondo me no Secondo me no
e l'errore L'errore che viene commesso
più spesso e che si pensi di fare un
favore ai detenuti se li si fa uscire Ah
è stato concesso il permesso premio a
quel detenuto titoli di giornale sono
stati fatti uscire di questi detenuti
titoli di
giornale uno pensa che lo si faccia per
altruismo ma in
realtà non vogliamo essere
altruisti ma forse non è meglio allora
essere anche egoisti Ma in questo
caso la soluzione coincide sapete perché
Perché
egoista voler vivere una società
migliore voler togliere queste persone
dalla nostra realtà
ma nessuno ci pensa che tanto torneranno
dopo 2 5 10 anni queste persone
torneranno E allora vogliamo che nella
nostra società torni un
delinquente magari che è peggiorato o
vogliamo che torni qualcuno che è stato
rieducato qualcuno che
può rientrare fare l'ingresso nella
nostra società e portare un
miglioramento che a cui magari è stato
insegnato un
mestiere qualsiasi Non lo so l'idraulico
o che magari ha potuto studiare
laurearsi e può uscire e contribuire in
qualche modo e allora scegliete voi se
essere altruisti o egoisti Ma di
sicuro la criminalità e la delinquenza
non si combatterà mai con il carcere ma
solo
rieducando questa è l'unica cosa che
posso
[Applauso]
dirvi
grazie